another day another wild outfit from
miss Bella Thorne I'm feeling good don't
worry shoot guys feeling about the 19
year old actress stepped out earlier
this week in Hollywood wearing this
special look a checkered cutout bodysuit
to complete with a rainbow a flame
design paired with some silver platform
boots some colorful jewelry a bold
glittery eye and yes a bright orange
beanie Bella was actually rocking that
same beanie on Thursday when news broke
that her freeform series famous and love
will return for season 2 she also
sported some similar head wear last week
when et caught up with her on the red
carpet where Bella broke down style for
us I do a lot of monochromatic stuff or
like super super matchy so I'm literally
head-to-toe and like white and red and
then I got the pop of yellow bag because
it competes with the red so it's a
little on footing which I like but it's
really eccentric
that's whatever the show I mean it's
like you guys don't like it I do though
so
[Music]